hi I'm anyway and I'm a mathematics
teacher when it comes to mathematical
reflection which i think is a very
missed out aspect of learning in the
mathematics classroom one of the things
I found most powerful to help students
you know adopt that attitude of thinking
about what they've just done and
actually learning from it is to you know
very simply just tweak your assessment
and give students multiple opportunities
to try something I mean that seems
really obvious so many things in life
for you give it a go the first time and
you're like I didn't work out we'll try
another way see if you can improve but
in mathematics we often say there's one
summative assessment at the end and once
that's over that was your last shot at
it now it's time to move on and I think
that's understandable in many ways
because teachers feel this immense
pressure of time but also it's
short-circuits student's ability to say
well I didn't really get trigonometry
the way that I thought maybe I should
revisit it the opportunity to develop
that mastery and to say well oh wait
this is important for the future I
really want to make sure I get this two
to retake a task and even if it's not
going to account for assessment and
reporting in the same way as the
original attempt the ability to say I
can improve you know this is not just
I'm locked in time I'm never going to
get better at this because I got a I got
a say on this task and that's the end of
it just that very simple tweak I found
has sort of opened the door to a whole
amount of mathematical reflection and
introspection that wasn't there before
because students are so busy just
marching through the syllabus dot points
and think about what comes next
[Music]